[Music]
think i can win all depends on the jury
carly
pick the right jury and you walk
d.j picks the jury in you get the guys
well they look young don't they that was
actor matthew mcconaughey playing jake
bergans
in the 1996 film a time to kill the
blockbuster hit was
adapted from john grisham's very first
novel of the same name
now the best-selling author is returning
to jake's story
in his new book called a time for mercy
it is his third novel
featuring the mississippi lawyer this
time jake finds himself
defending a 16-year-old accused of
killing a local deputy
john grisham joins us first on cbs this
morning john good morning welcome
what took you back to jake again
uh good morning anthony um good to see
you guys again i wish i
could be in the studio in new york we do
too here on the farm in virginia and
it's
beautiful here um you know time to kill
is my favorite book
it's my favorite locale those are my
favorite characters it's very
autobiographical and uh
that's what i enjoy writing i i have to
say i'm shocked to hear you say that i
mean you've written
35 books you've sold a gazillion books
and that's legitimately a gazillion it's
been certified
but but the first one is still your
favorite
yeah for a lot of sentimental reasons
but it was also very autobiographical
and it was uh written at a time when i
didn't know if the book was ever gonna
get published and it was about
i was living that life as a small town
lawyer in mississippi
and struggling and dreaming of the big
case and so i'm very uh
a lot of nostalgia when it comes to a
time to kill and jake and
and those characters and i love to go
back there and write these stories
uh in in this in this book jake uh
is given a case that he doesn't really
want to take which a local deputy has
been shot
um you've been through this yourself
when you were a lawyer i've been
assigned cases you didn't really want
yeah a lot of small counties small
jurisdictions in the country there's no
public defender's office and so when
there's a crime especially a serious
crime
the local judges have to assign the
defense to the local bar
and i experienced it when there's a
really terrible crime the lawyers really
don't want the cases
because they're you know they're very
difficult this is a story about a
you know a dead cop in a small town and
no lawyer wants to step
in for the defense jake sure didn't want
to but he was kind of forced to and he
gradually uh realized that it was him or
no one so he
came to the defense of this kid and the
kid's family and
and we go to trial you uh john obviously
this is a this is a very
contentious time in terms of the police
and the justice system
did that play into your thinking in
writing this book and has your own
attitude toward the justice system
changed in the years that you've been
writing these books
it certainly has changed it goes back to
about 15 years ago when i wrote a book
called the innocent man a non-fiction
account of a wrongful conviction and
i think from that point on i became more
aware of all the problems we
have with the criminal justice system a
lot of issues
i've written about a lot of them and i
will continue to do so because that's
where my
interests lie uh but no when i started
the book i was not really thinking about
uh the police or those issues it just
kind of happened
and there's no real mystery here in the
first chapter you know who killed who
and so the question becomes how do you
handle a 16 year old kid charged with
capital murder
the story takes place in 1990 and back
then it was common in the death belt to
put
teenagers on trial for capital murder
and so the book sort of explores
you know the issues there what are how
do you handle these kids
youngsters who commit terrible crimes
and and how do you
protect the victims and i don't really
answer the question in the book because
i don't know the answer
yeah john i want to ask you real quickly
about you you posted a video
uh of matthew mcconaughey about how he
got the part
in that movie which you actually had
approval on and and
and from what i understand your wife
played a clinical role in that casting
they sent us the old uh vhf tape we
plugged it in the vcr and there was
matthew doing a screen test
and from the moment renee saw matthew
she said that's him he's got the looks
the charisma
the southern accent we had not seen him
act uh but we said this is our guy and
he did a wonderful job
could you ask him anthony why he looks
like an ad in kovac
why john grisham no matter where you are
yeah you look like an ad for how to how
to survive covey yes
you look like an ad for the good life
john grisham i can't wait to see your
shoes we're in quarantine
yes how do you do we're in warranty
we're on the farm in quarantine
quarantine never looked so good john
grisham thank you so much for being with
us
a time for mercy is on sale today we'll
be right back